sur deux depuis septembre c'est un
nouveau rituel qui se répète dans la
grande salle commune de Boy Street
chandails et coton water se transforme
en canevas ici on se sert du dessin de
l'impression pour s'exprimer
le premier atelier était donné
l'occasion de la Journée nationale de
vérité de réconciliation explique la
cour de la crise du centre à une minute
la grande majorité des itinérans sont
autochtones une réalité qui se raconte
désormais sur du tissu
pour plusieurs clients de base Street
c'est un premier contact avec l'art
depuis qu'ils sont dans la rue les
techniques d'impression est plutôt
facile et très manuelle et le résultat
tangibles
menuisier apprécie le pouvoir travailler
de nouveau avec ses mains
ça donne aux gens quelque chose à faire
et on reçoit un chandail se
félicite-t-il
mais ici souvent repart avec plus qu'un
vêtement le programme permet d'établir
un premier contact avec des personnes
qui autrement ne se laissaient pas
approcher
[Musique]
l'expert de l'impression c'est lui tu
avais sorti et tatoueur et artiste il
pratique l'impression depuis son
adolescence beautiful
les gens dit-il quand tu as vu ça a été
approché pour organiser et bénévolement
l'atelier il a accepté tout de suite une
façon pour lui de partager sa passion et
redonner une communauté trop souvent
négligée
une cinquantaine de chandails coton wati
peut Vinci être donné à chaque atelier
dans l'hiver glacial d'edminton peu de
source de chaleur peuvent créer autant
de fierté ici Mathieu Gohier
Radio-Canada Edmonton